bei mir im studio jetzt mein kollege kai
feldhaus kai der fall maddie ihm den
begleitet zu seit jahren für uns jetzt
christian b gestern also braunschweig
gewesen und dann ins krankenhaus
gekommen bast details weiß man was genau
hat sich da abgespielt
das ist wahnsinnig dubiose geschichte so
was kennt man eigentlich so aus einem
sonntagabend tatort oder so also aus
hollywood-filmen christian b ist um 11
10 mit einem gefangenen transporter aus
der jva kiel im brandschutt braunschweig
angekommen und dann in die
gewahrsamszelle verbracht worden um dort
zu warten dass eine anhörung beginnt da
ging es um die möglicherweise vorzeitige
entlassung aus seiner haftstrafe wegen
drogenhandels 540 minuten später stoppte
dann ein notarztwagen vor dem
krankenhaus und zwei sanitäter eilten
herein spam die kollegen die vor der tür
standen
die wurden nicht eingelassen und es
wurde auch insgesamt nicht erzählt was
denn da passiert ist
wir haben einige dinge in erfahrung
bringen könnte durchgesickert sind
ganz offensichtlich ist es in der
gewahrsamszelle zu einer
auseinandersetzung gekommen
in dieser zelle war jetzt nicht
christian b und weitere strafgefangene
sondern christian b und justizbeamte da
muss es zu einer auseinandersetzung
gekommen sein und im rahmen dieser
auseinandersetzung soll b zu fall
gekommen seien und sich zwei rippen
gebrochen haben
wie genau das zu stande gekommen ist das
wissen wir nicht aber wir wissen auch
dass es danach eine relativ lautstärke
also auch noch draußen zu hören der
auseinandersetzung gab zwischen
christian b s verteidiger und den
justizbeamten in dem unter anderem der
satz gefallen sein sollte das sei ein
unwürdiges verhalten für beamte und
video aufnahmen seien umgehend zu
löschen was die hintergründe sind das
wissen wir noch nicht warum war
christian b überhaupt gestern
braunschweig hat das was mit dem fall
maddie zu tun
dort wird ja gegen ihn ermittelt nein
das hatte mit dem fall maddie konkreten
nichts zu tun
christian besitzt derzeit in kiel einer
haftstrafe von einem jahr und neun
monaten wegen drogenhandels ab die hat
er zu zwei dritteln abgesessen das heißt
er hat das anrecht auf eine anhörung in
der darüber verhandelt wird ob er
vorzeitig auf bewährung frei kommen kann
das ist im falle christian b eigentlich
nur die produktion von spesen also dass
da wird jetzt nichts passieren weil wir
wissen ja dass noch anhängig ist eine
haftstrafe von sieben jahren für die
vergewaltigung einer amerikanerin in
portugal 2005 diese haftstrafe diese
diese sieben jahre die sind noch nicht
rechtskräftig die werden jetzt gerade
noch vom bgh geprüft aber selbst wenn
christian b seiner haftstrafe jetzt
abgesessen hat und zwar voll abgesessen
hat wird er dann noch mal in
untersuchungshaft überstellt weil der
einfach nur soviel dran hängt das heißt
dass diese anhörung gestern stattfand
das war jetzt sein gutes recht aber er
wird deswegen nicht freier nicht vorher
aus der haft entlassen
wenn wir jetzt mal auf den fall maddie
schauen dort gab es jetzt zwischen den
verschiedenen ermittlern aus portugal
scotland yard also england und
deutschland eintreffen und danach auch
vorwürfe gegen die deutschen ermittler
vor allem von portugiesischer seite dass
sie eigentlich so gut wie nichts gegen
christian b in der hand haben was ist da
dran
ja da muss man ein bisschen vorsichtig
sein wir wissen dass es ein treffen
zwischen bka scotland yard und der der
portugiesischen kriminalpolizei wir
wissen dass sich die ermittler dort
ausgetauscht haben über den
ermittlungsstand und die frage was man
jetzt mal als nicht es noch tun kann
kann man auch jemanden fragen kann man
noch immer graben kann man noch immer
mit hunden hingehen danach tauchte dann
eine e-mail auf die aus kreisen der
portugiesischen kriminalpolizei stammt
und in der sich ein beamter recht
wortreich darüber beschwert wie schlecht
die ermittlung der deutschen sein
da steht drin dass das werde ich gar
nicht ermittelt es werde noch versucht
den verdächtigen im gefängnis zu
behalten ihm das anzuhängen
man muss das aber mit vorsicht genießen
wir wissen aus den letzten 13 jahren
dass es da immer wieder zu
eifersüchteleien kommt dass die
portugiesen sich darüber beschwert haben
als die engländer plötzlich die
federführung übernehmen und dann
den fall ganz neu aufgerollt haben die
portugiesen waren sich relativ früh
sicher dass maddies eltern an ihrem
verschwinden schuld sind die engländer
haben die eltern entlastet da gab es
also immer einfach süchte laien und
frotzeleien und deswegen muss man jetzt
ein bisschen vorsichtig sein
ob das jetzt tatsächlich bestand hat
also ob da wirklich was dran ist an
dieser kritik oder ob da einfach jemand
sauer ist dass die deutschen jetzt
plötzlich so weit vorne sind
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren